merci Max Brisson de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heur vous
êtes élu des Pyrénées Atlantiques
membres du groupe les républicains
vice-président de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication on va bien sûr longuement
revenir sur les annonce de Gabriel Atal
et sur l'audition de Jean-Michel
Blanquer que vous avez entendu hier mais
d'abord un mot sur l'actualité et
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé samedi
soir et cette attaque au couteau et
ellisabeth born hier dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale qui s'en est
vivement prise au rassemblement national
quand la France est touchée il y a ceux
qui agissent avec responsabilité et puis
il y a vous et votre parti qui une
nouvelle fois vous précipitez dans le
seul but d'alimenter les polémiques elle
a raison la première ministre je ne suis
pas sûr parce qu'à force de ne pas dire
ce que ressentent les Français on laisse
le rassemblement national finalement
exprimer ce que ressentent profondément
les Français on ferait mieux de regarder
les choses en face de voir que notre
pays est menacé par un
islamisme radical extrêmement dangereux
et par une ambiance qui règne dans le
pays d'affrontement et qui favorise des
gestes absolument insupportaes comme
ceux qui sont passés à birakeim dans le
quartier de La Tour Efel samedi donc moi
je je veux bien que on utilise madame la
Première ministre utilise aussi cette
affaire dans son combat contre le
rassemblement national à force de ne pas
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
cela finit par alimenter le
rassemblement nationale je pense que
ceux qui sont au pouvoir actuellement
sont largement ceux qui alimente le
développement du rassemblement national
en faisant semblant de le combattre don
Emmanuel Macron qui dans sa réaction à
cette attaque de Paris n'a pas employer
le mot islamisme oui Emmanuel Macron de
toute façon a décidé que le
rassemblement national c'est son
meilleur à liby son meilleur àout pardon
c'est celui qui lui permet d'avoir été
réélu ce qui lu permet deavoir gagné les
élections en 2017 etêtre d'avoir été
réélu en 2022 donc oui il y a en face à
faceace que Macron cherche avec le
rassemblement national mais ce face- à
faceace est mort ire pour le pays il
faut en sortir pour l'avenir même de
notre démocratie est-ce que quand même
cette attaque elle pose des questions
notamment sur le le suivi psychiatrique
elle pose aussi des questions sur le
suivi des radicalisés qui sortent de
prison puisque laassillant avait fait de
la prison pour préparation d'une attaque
terroriste Jordane Bardella du
rassemblement national a remis sur la
table la question de la rétention de
sûreté est-ce que pour vous il faut la
mettre en le pose en tous les cas la
question de la manière dont notre État
de droit est en capacité de combattre
projet politique qui a déclaré la guerre
à la démocratie française à la
République française est-ce que nos
outils sont suffisants aujourd'hui je ne
le pense pas est-ce que l'État de droit
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui et derriè
lequel on se drape facilement est le
meilleur moyen de faire la guerre on ne
fait pas oblig la guerre avec un état de
droit qui très justement protège
beaucoup de libertés mais ces libertés
sont dévoyées par ceux qui de toute
façon veulent les abattre donc il y a un
moment où il faut se donner les moyens
de faire la guerre c'est une question
très légitime qui n'est pas le monopole
du rassemblement national mais à force
de justement stigmatiser ceux qui disent
ce que je viens de dire on alimente le
rassemblement national et on ne règle
pas la question qui est celle de
l'angoisse des Français dans les rues de
Paris dans un quartier tout à fait
tranquille on peut être assassiné par un
fou qui se réclame d'une idéologie qui
veut tuer la République et la démocratie
on va parler des questions d'éducation
puisque vous êtes l'un des spécialistes
de ces sujets ici au Sénat et d'abord
l'enquête PISA de l'OCDE qui a été
révélé hier en quête sur l'éducation qui
sont les compétences des élèves de 15
ans la France est 22e sur 38 pays en
math 24e en compréhension de l'écrit les
résultats sont les plus bas parmi les
plus bas jamais mesurés est-ce que ça
illustre l'effondrement du niveau
scolaire dans notre pays une évaluation
ne dit rien c'est le le le SOMUM le
cumul des évaluations qui dit que notre
système est au bord de la bascule au
bord de l'effondrement les évaluations
PISA mais aussi bien d'autres
évaluations les évaluations teams pour
parler le vocabulaire des technicienes
ou les évaluations du ministère
d'éducation nationale toutes disent que
ça deringle que la capacité des élèves à
maîtriser les compétences et les
connaissances fondamentales ne cessent
de reculer pour les plus en difficulté
mais aussi pour les meilleurs ce que
l'on ne dit rarement donc il y a une
bascule qui est en train de s'opérer
notre système scolaire est au bord de
l'effondrement donc il faut des mesures
aujourd'hui de rupture et excusez-moi il
y a des gens qui portent une
responsabilité toutes cell toutes celles
et tous ceux qui ont dit par exemple que
tout élément de sanction tout élément
d'évaluation de notation stigmatise les
élèves vous savez ce discours de la
bienveillance poussé jusqu'à l'extrême
qui énerve le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale il y a des gens qui ont
affirmé au effort qu'il ne fallait pas
de redouvelement pas de sanction que
tout ceci pouvait stigmatiser c'est
plutôt les politiques de gauche que vous
pointez du doigt vous aussi toute une
hiérarchie du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale des recteurs des directeurs de
l'administration centrale j'ai eu
récemment sur les réseaux sociaux une
altercation avec un ancien secrétaire
général du ministère ancien recteur
ancien directeur de cabinet deun
ministre de gauche et qui continue à
dire que c'était des idées
réactionnaires mais excusez-moi leurs
idées à eux ont conduit à cet échec
patent dont ils sont responsables sont
pas les idées de droite qui sont
aujourd'hui en cause parce que il est à
peu près assuré qu'elle n'énerve pas
l'éducation nationale depuis de longues
décennies et si on essayait ces idées au
lieu de les traiter de réactionnaire et
de rarde voyez c'est un peu comme quand
la Première ministre stigmatise une
force une autre force politique nous
sommes sur le champ de l'éducation
constamment stigmatisé alors moi j'ai
pris du plaisir j'ai pris du plaisir à
entendre le ministre d'éducation
nationale finalement dire ce que nous
disons depuis des années que fait la
politique dans la droite on va rappel il
employaé les mots vérité exigence pas de
tabou relever le niveau est-ce que c'est
la politique j'éta polémique mais je ne
gagnerai jamais le prix de l'humour il
dérive gentiment vers la droite et s'il
continue je lui proposerai une carte au
Républicain mais c'est pas parce qu'il
dit des choses justes que je vais m'y
opposer parce que c'est àal qui le dit
oui le redoublement est un outil pas le
seul pas l'unique mais il est un outil
oui le dernier mot au professeur c'est
quelque chose d'important parce que
passer la classe supérieure quand vous
étiez élève quand j'étais élève c'était
un véritable challenge c'était quelque
chose qu'on se fixait comme objectif
aujourd'hui c'est automatique les
parents ont toujours raison et bien non
excusez-moi les professeurs sont des
experts ils connaissent leur métier ils
ont été préparés et c'est à eux de dire
si le passage de la classe supérieur est
une bonne chose pour l'élèv ou une
mauvaise chose le ministre le dit il a
raison et c'est pas parce que c'est un
ministre de Macron qui le dit que je
vais dire que c'est une bêtise puisque
nous disons depuis longtemps le brevet
des collèges certification et nécessité
de l'obtenir pour passer au lycée c'est
une bonne idée mais pourquoi don du sens
de l'exigence il a dit plutôt correctif
académique également un prof met un 8/
20 derrière il était remonté pour en
faire un 11 ou 12 c'est fini quand un
prof dit note 8/ 20 c'est qu'il pense en
conscience avec son expertise que cette
prestation vous vite sur vert toutes les
corrections c'est cette bienveillance
cette non stigmatisation qui est l'alpha
et l'oméga de la politique du ministère
depuis 25 ans mais excusez-moi cette
politique sont des choix et ces choix
ont été portés par un courant et pas
qu'un courant politique he c'est courant
des sciences de l'éducation qui faisait
que on ne pouvait pas considérer les
élèves tels qu'ils sont mais tels que
finalement dans l'idéal ils auraient dû
être excusez-moi il est temps de revenir
aux réalités au vérités et de considérer
que tous les élèves en 6e en CM2 ou en
ou en 4e ne sont pas au même niveau et
que donc il est nécessaire vous savez
l'honneur de tu mis de professeur c'est
d'enseigner aux élèves en difficulté
c'est d'enseigner au aux élèves qui sont
dans l'excellence ce qui est impossible
à faire contrairement à ce que pensent
les pédagogues de salon c'est
d'enseigner à la fois en même temps aux
élèves en très grandes difficulté et aux
élèves dans l'excellence ceux qui n'ont
plus vu une classe depuis des années
théorisent là-dessus les professeurs qui
sont sur le terrain vous disent c'est
impossible donc il est temps de finir
avec la pédagogie de salon il remet en
place les groupes de niveau avec plus de
moyens pour les groupes d'élèves en
difficulté il dit qu'il y aura des
recrutements de poste parce qu'il veut
pas que dans ces groupes il ait plus
d'une quinzaine d'élèves là aussi vous
saluez mais il met fin au collège unique
sans le dire alors il serait urgent ah
ben il a dit he il a dit après des
années de glissement vers un collège
uniforme plutôt qu'unique j'assume de
dire qu' je remercie d'ailleurs de nous
avoir empronté le concept de collège
uniforme qui a été utilisé pendant
l'élection présidentielle par Valérie
pcress dont j'avait participé à
l'élaboration du projet sur l'éducation
en effet le collège unique é une idée de
droite qui était une belle idée qui
était l'idée que finalement tout les
enfants de France auraient un socle de
connaissance et de compétences identique
jusqu'à la 3è mais on est à dérivé du
collège unique en collège uniforme en
mettant tous les élèves dans des classes
hétérogènes don le retour des groupes de
niveau c'est une une excellente chose il
y a un problème c'est c'est par exemple
aussi est-ce que tous les enfants
aujourd'hui accèdent au collège sans que
l'on vérifie leurs connaissances et
leurs compétences issu de l'école
primaire le ministre parle beaucoup des
savoirs fondamentaux il dit que le
prevet des collèges sera nécessaire pour
passer au lycée quel brevet est-ce que
ce brevet sera renforcé mais il ne
nullement parler de la nécessité
d'évaluer les savoirs fondamentaux
laisser partir des enfants en collège
lorsqu'il ne maîtrise pas les savoirs de
l'école primaire c'est les envoyés au
CPIP et là-dessus le ministre a été très
silencieux donc là y a encore des des
manquementsoup il y a beaucoup de
progrès encore à faire mais ENF
l'élèveal est incontestablement en
progrès pour vous il sera le ministre
qui remonte le niveau de l'école non on
verra bien à l'usage vous avez
l'éducation nationale c'est le temps
long c'est un pe ce qu'il a dit hier il
a dit il faut au moins 10 ans il faut 10
ans pour remonter le niveau mais est-ce
que ça veut dire qu'il y a des
générations sacrifié l'heure de vérité
pour le ministre ça sera sa capacité à
énerver sa volonté dans l'immense
système extrêmement vertical qui est
l'éducation nationale voilà pourquoi moi
je prendne quelque chose de très
différent je prendne l'autonomie la
liberté TER je prne la réforme par
l'établissement il continue dans la
logique de ses prédécesseurs la réforme
par le haut il a une volonté ce que je
crains très fortement c'est que cette
volonté s'épuise dans ce qui est la
verticalité du système la meilleure idée
lorsqu'elle arrive dans l'établissement
elle a été broyée par la mécanique de
l'éducation nationale et en général la
meillorité a été bouer et surtout passer
au GR au crible de ce que pense cette
verticalité qui est plutôt en opposition
avec les idées du ministre donc
croyez-moi elle sera en capacité de
réduire les appétences de gravatal mais
nous l'encouragerons à continuer dans
cette voie on va continuer à parler des
questions éducation vous avez auditionné
hier l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale Jean-Michel Blanquer dans le
cadre des travaux du Sénat sur les
menaces et agression dont les
enseignants sont victimes on va voir ce
qui s'est dit pendant cette audition
avec Steve
Jourdin
[Musique]
bonjour St bonjouran bonjour monsieur le
sénateur bonjour et C Jean-Michel blanc
été donc auditionné par les sénateurs
oui suite des travaux de la commission
d'enquête mise en place au mois de juin
l'objectif bien c'est de comprendre les
mécanismes et les défaillances qui ont
conduit à l'assassinat de Samuel paaty
la sœur de Samuel Michell a été entendue
au mois d'octobre hier c'était donc au
tour de Jean-Michel Blanquer ministre de
l'éducation au moment des faits d'être
auditionné question Samuel paatti a-t-il
été lâché par l'Éducation nationale
c'est une accusation qui revient
régulièrement depuis son meurtre écoutez
la réponse de Jean-Michel Blanquer vous
pourriez interroger par exemple enfin
elle le sera dans le cadre euh
judiciaire mais la la la principale du
collège de boison et je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire qu'elle a abandonné Samuel
Patti euh et elle était elle était
l'institution était l'élément le plus
proche de de l'institution à ce
moment-là l'expression euh éducation
nationale ayant lâché le Samuel Patti me
paraît une question un sujet qui doit
être regardé de très près quand on
regarde chacune des étapes encore une
fois je ne veux pas entrer dans les
détails prudence prudence donc chez
Jean-Michel Blanquer on rappelle que le
premier volet judiciaire de l'attentat
de Samuel pti a débuté la semaine
dernière et que par principe une
commission d'enquête parlementaire ne
peut pas se substituer aux travaux de la
justice un rapport de l'Inspection
générale était au cœur de l'audition oui
Samuel Patier est assassiné le 16
octobre 2 20 de mois plus tard un
rapport de l'inspection générale de
l'éducation nationale est publié Il r
les jours qui ont précédé l'assassinat
notamment au sein de son établissement
rapport d'une vingtaine de pages qui
avait à l'époque suscité beaucoup
d'émotions il y a quelques semaines
Michel paatti donc la sœur de Samuel a
estimé devant vous devant les les
sénateurs que l'enquête qui a débouché
sur ce rapport a été mal conduite
Jean-Michel Blanquer a répondu à cette
accusation écoutez on peut évidemment
pointer des incomplétudes euh puisqu à
la fois les avantages et les
inconvénients d'avoir été rapides
souvent on reproche au rapport d'arriver
après longtemps après cette fois-ci euh
celui-ci a été a été réactif et a permis
de recueillir à chaud des des
témoignages monsieur le sénateur on
entend Jean-Michel Blanquer beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de prudence il s'est
pas un peu défaussé Michel Blanquer moi
j'ai un petit peu gêné parce que le
cadre dans lequel cette commission
d'enquête cette mission de contrôle se
déroule est marqué par l'enquête
judiciaire en cours et donc le président
François Noël buffet le président de la
commission des lois à juste titre
rappelé au ministres oui plusieurs fois
qu'il devait être prudent dans ses
réponses par rapport à des question de
collègues qui
pointai le drame de l'assassinat de
Samuel batti et les conséquences dans
lesquelles ce drame s'est déroulé et
peut-être l'absence de protection par la
hiérarchie de l'éducation nationale au
moment où les alertes étaient évidentes
voilà je ne suis pas considéré je suis
pas considéré comme quelqu'un de très
enclair à à souteniranmichel au cours
des des années où il était ministre mais
je reconnais que là sa parole était
limitée parce que sinon il pouvait être
avoir des ennuis avec la justice pour
avoir dit des choses devant la
commission d'enquête alors qu'il doit
les réserver à l'enquête judiciaire il
paraît évident que la protection de
l'enseignant la protection de Samuel
pati le soutien de Samuel pti n'a
peut-être pas été à la hauteur du drame
mais voyez on réécrit ce qui s'est passé
avant le meurtre à l'ORD de cet
assassinat et est évident que ça donne
une dimension supplémentaire au soutien
affaibli au soutien peut-être
insuffisant qu'avait reçu le professeur
Samuel paatti je comprends la colère de
la famille je comprends la colère de la
sœur de Samuel pati mais on ne peut pas
faire le procès ce matin à Jean-Michel
blankerer de ne pas avoir dit devant la
commission d'enquête ce qu'il doit dire
devant la justice attendons que la
justice passe et notre travail à nous il
est un petit peu différent notre travail
à nous c'est de voir si des mesures ont
été prises depuis h pour que ça ne se
reproduise pas excusez-moi les mesures à
prendre c'est dans deux champs est-ce
que le pas de vague vous savez ce cet
omerta cette loi de silence qui règne à
l'éducation nationale qui fait qu'on
règle les problèmes en interne qu'il
faut surtout pas qu'il sortent sur la
place publique de manière à ce que
l'institution ne soit pas sal est-ce que
ce pas de c'est une question qu'il faut
que l'on creuse est-ce que vraiment
toute la tout le système toute la
verticalité du système est bien
maintenant dans l'idée que tout doit
être dévoilé et que le soutien doit être
total que tout professeur qui est menacé
dans l'enseignement de certaines parties
du programme ou dans l'enseignement des
principes de laïcité doit être
immédiatement soutenu protégé vous en
doutez encore parce que là Gabriel hatal
pour revenir à lui il dit qu'il veut
mettre fin au pas de vaguisme oui mais
Gabriel hatal dit la même chose que
Jean-Michel Blanquer il y a que
peut-être pas bend qui était une
parenthèse dans cette volonté
gouvernementale est-ce que cela descend
dans tous les établissements est-ce que
finalement comme je le demandais au
ministre le professeur qui évite le
clash n'est pas beaucoup plus apprécié
parce qu'il évite des parties du
programme parce qu'il n'enseigne plus la
choix parce que il ne porte plus
l'enseignement des du principe de
laïcité dans sa spécificité française
est-ce que celui qui finalement passe à
côté n'est pas finalement préféré à
celui qui porte le projet du de la
laïité française et qui enseigne la
totalité du programme y compris ce qui
déplaî au aux islamistes et à ceux qui
sont les adversaires de la République
c'est cela aujourd'hui la vraie question
est-ce que tout est fait pour que les
programmes tels qu'ils sont soient
enseignés et pour que le principe de
laïcité soit parfaitement porté à
l'école public ça c'est le c'est le pas
de vague mais aussi est-ce que les
enseignants sont assez armés formés au
principe de l'ité moi j'ai un immense
doute parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
l'université qui forme les professeurs à
particulier du premier degré et ce que
ce que je sais ce que je ressens c'est
que l'université est traversée par des
courants qui aujourd'hui remett en cause
la dimension exceptionnelle du principe
de laïcité en France laïcité relative
laïcité contestée moi je ne conteste pas
l'idée que les querelles du monde
traversent l'université en revanche que
je conteste c'est qu'elle traverse
l'école l'école a toujours porté un le
projet de la République qui était le le
qui était fondé sur le principe de la
licité et aujourd'hui je ne suis pas
assure que les professeurs soient armés
pour le défendre en parlant d'armes il
est aussi question de la sécurité de ces
professeurs dans les établissements
question simple euh il faut un policier
dans chaque établissement en France
aujourd'hui dans certain dans la plupart
des établissements c'est pas nécessaire
heureusement excusez-moi dans les écoles
rurales primaires de mon département qui
compte deux trois classes en pleine
ruralité ça serait un nonsens qu'il ait
des endroits où la présence policière
sécurise les élèves les parents et les
professeurs c'est c'est c'est certain
c'est d'ailleurs extrêmement triste mais
il faut le systématiser le systématisé
n'aurait aucun sens le développer là où
partout c'est nécessaire aurait du sens
en revanche moi je je redis qu'il faut
armer aussi intellectuellement et puis
surtout ne pas tergiverser quand on
conteste les institution de la
République quand on conteste le principe
de laïcité et qu'on introduit ça dans
l'enseignement des professeurs on n'en
fait pas des porteurs d'un principe or
là contrairement à ce que dit le
ministre hier la laïcité dans notre pays
n'est pas une valeur une valeur ça peut
se discuter c'est un principe
constitutionnel dans le vivre ensemble
dans une
démocratie et dans un état de droit un
principe constitutionnel ça ne se
conteste pas sa saptique et donc
aujourd'hui les professeurs ne sont pas
armés sur cette idée très forte la
laicité ne se débat pas elle s'applique
Jean-Michel Blanquer en parlant de
laïcité rappeler sa sa position
évidemment il demande une homogénéité
idéologique dans l'éducation nationale
et au niveau politique vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure la parenthèse Papen yille
est-ce qu'il y a une ligne claire au
sein d'exécutif aujourd'hui en matière
de laïcité oh je pense que PAP a été
pour le coup une parenthèse il
s'agissait de calmer les salles des
professeurs non pas sur ce sujet-là mais
sur beaucoup d'autres sujets dans le
durant lequel le ministère blancaire
avveit provoqué beaucoup d'allergies
donc face aux allergies blancaires il
fallait une sorte de cataplasme qui
s'est appelé PAP c'est fini la
parenthèse est terminée il y a
continuité entre les propos de Gabriel
hatal et ceux de Jean-Michel Blanquer en
en revanche je ne suis pas sûr que les
mesures de fond soient prises moi je
prône de manière urgente que l'éducation
nationale reprenne la main sur la
formation des professeurs il y a un
certain nombre de sujets sur lequel on
ne peut pas les laisser à l'université
parce que les querelles universitaires
ne servent pas la formation des
professeurs du 1er degré peut-être même
du second degré merci Steve à tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure on parlera de
Bruno Le Maire tout à l'heure ce sera à
suivre dans le club on termine par
l'actualité dans votre région Max
Brisson on va retrouver Jefferson des
sport bonjour Jefferson merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous grand reporter pour le
journal Sud-Ouest Jefferson on va
revenir avec vous sur la question du
logement dans certaines zones
touristiques oui bonjour Max Brisson on
va parler d'immobilier parce que fin
novembre le Sénat a adopté un de vos
amendements visant à réduire l'avantage
fiscal des meublés de tourisme l'idée
est de faire revenir certains de ses
biens dans le parc des locations de
longue durée et aujourd'hui l'assemblée
nationale examine une proposition de loi
sur le sujet pour remédier à ces
déséquilibres du marché locatif dans les
zones tendues les zones touristiques
c'est ce qu'on connaitt très bien dans
notre région dans le Sud-Ouest c'est
dans votre département des pyranées
Atlantique Max Brisson est-ce que ce
texte a une chance de passer parce que
au Sénat on a vu le ministre du Budget
Thomas casazna va être plutôt réticent à
vos amendements il a émis un avis
défavorable du gouvernement il estime
qu'on ne peut pas toucher la fiscalité
par ce biais là des amendements ce
serait trop
hasardeuxport je continuerai le combat
jusqu'à la victoire je sais que ça un
combat de longue haleine mais moi je ne
peux plus supporter qu'il soit beaucoup
plus intéressant dans certains
territoires de notre pays de faire de la
location saisonnière plutôt que
deallocation à l'année je pense qu'il
faut moins rétablir l'équilibre donc je
continuerai ce combat oui c'est vrai moi
je constate que le gouvernement hésite
depuis 2 ans 3 ans on nous renvoie de
mission parlementair à Conseil national
de la refondation de conseil national de
la refondation en mission parlementaire
je verrai ce qui le sort qui sera
réservé à la proposition de loi portée
par n Le Meur et par un député de mon
département Inaki et Chanis je verrai
bien en effet si le gouvernement la
marque une volonté pendant le débat au
Sénat en effet on a vu un gouvernement
peureux voilà moi je sais pas pourquoi
je il s'agit bien sûr de protéger les
petits épargnants qui ont acheté un
appartement qui ont un complément de
retraite en location il s'agit de ne pas
il s'agit de frapper la spéculation il
il s'agit de frapper ceux qui dans ma
vie la biarite achètent 3 4 5 6
appartements pour faire de l'hôtellerie
sans les normes dehôtellerie sans les
contraintes de l'hôtellerie sans la
fiscalité de l'hôtellerie il s'agit
aussi de remettre sur le marché des
locations à l'année puisqu'on a une
véritable évaporation des locations à
l'année au profit des locations
saisonnaires et cela déstabilise
l'habitat donc ce combat je continuerai
à le mener je ne sens pas en effet
aujourd'hui je m'interroge je ne sens
pas une volonté très très forte du
gouvernement y aurait-il une sorte de
lobby Airbnb qui monte très haut
jusqu'au sommet de l'État c'est vraiment
une vraie question parce que ça fait 3
ans qu'on fait des rond dans l'eau sur
le sujet ma une dernière question est-ce
que c'est au propriétaires de faire cet
acte de solidarité pour régler ce
problème de la crise du logement qui est
particulèement aigu dans les zones
touristiques et notamment dans notre
région pour le propriétaire il est plus
avantageux de louer à l'année ce qui
nécessite aussi de resécuriser la
location à l'année de redonner des
droits au propriétairees si c'est plus
intéressant fiscalement et en terme de
pratique de faire de loocation à l'année
et bien les propriétaires choisiront ce
qui est le plus avantageux aujourd'hui
il faut être un saint laïque dans
certains territoires pour faire de
l'allocation à l'année plus
d'embêtement moins de ressources et plus
de fiscalité alors au moins sur ces
trois sujets dans le cas d'une loi de
finance on peut faire tomber la niche
fiscale un abattement de 71 % dans le
droit actuel cert le gouvernement l'a
réduit mais le gouvernement n'a pas
supprimé dans le projet de loi qui a été
débattu au Sénat et qui venait par le
493 de l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement n'a pas supprimé les faits
d'auè pour l'instant moi ce que je veux
combattre cet effet d'obain qui rend
plus avantageux de louer en meublé
touristique que de louer à l'année je
veux au moins que l'on soit à chance
égal et puis après les propriétaires
feront leur propres choix par rapport à
leur stratégie personnelle merci
Jefferson on regarde la Une de sudouest
c'est Gabriel Atal Atal veut tout
changer c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup Jefferson merci Max merci
à vous d'avoir été avec nous pendant
cette première demi-heure dans